hey there i'm philip molina and this is
a breakdown of Walking Dead Season six
Episode six always accountable and this
was another one of those sideways
stories that's kind of adjacent to the
main story of Alexandria and the writer
of this episode packed it full of
references so get ready for like a
really in-depth analysis of the story
the characters and imagery also a few
moments that you might have missed and
obviously they're gonna be spoilers for
the episode ahead but there also be some
teeny tiny ones from the comics they
don't really give anything away they're
just kind of showing where we're kind of
headed but let's get right into it first
up as always let's take a look at the
opening images of the episode we are
once again dropped back into this very
long day that all of our characters are
experiencing in their own way but this
time it's Abraham Sasha and Daryl and
their efforts to lead the herd 20 miles
away from Alexandria now take note of
this view behind them the dreaded wall
of walkers ever so slowly following but
it's always there with seemingly no end
in sight and we will definitely come
back to that so moments after the group
is attacked and they split up Daryl
wipes out and we see what's an easily
miscible moment here when the camera
pulls back and it shows another
motorcyclist who appears to have
suffered some bad luck also and the
positioning of Daryl alongside that body
is clearly intentional this moments
actually setting up Daryl's entire
character arc for the episode but I'll
get back to that when we're closer to
the end of the story then after Darrell
gets taken by a roaming group of
Runaways it's kind of hard to catch what
they're saying as Daryl comes in and out
of consciousness but there's this easily
miscible exchange right here referring
to Daryl's crossbow now this moment
foreshadows not only the events at the
end of the episode when they take
Daryl's crossbow away from him again but
it's actually setting up who this guy
really is and I'm not gonna go too deep
into spoiler territory here but let's
just say this guy has already been
confirmed as being Dwight he's a man who
becomes very influential to the plot and
whose signature weapon is you guessed it
a crossbow let's keep going
so while The Runaways search for someone
named Patti Daryl and Dwight have a
little bit of a debate about whether or
not trusting people is stupid I don't
think it'd be stupid right now and then
Daryl manages to escape for a moment
only to be attacked by a pretty
awesome-looking Walker he's totally
covered in
and he's actually a reference to the
work of Bernie Wrightson who is the
co-creator of Swamp Thing though I think
it looks a little bit more like zombie
Groot
which idea for next year's Halloween
costume and then when Darryl sees that
he's accidentally taken a cooler full
insulin that the runaways had saved for
that little type Tina diabetes girl he
realizes he has to get it back to them
and this is a great example of just how
far Darryl has come since his beginnings
on the show and the show wanted to
subtly remind us of this journey with a
very missable detail just a few seconds
before this shot so you see that flower
that is a Cherokee rose which happens to
be the title of an episode from way back
and season two of the show was the
endless search for Sofia days and here's
Daryl himself explaining what it means
Cherokee rose when American soldiers
were moving Indians off their land the
Cherokee mothers were crying so much cuz
they were losing her little ones along
the way
the next day this rose started to grow
right where the mother's tears come
strength Oh since that was the first
moment where we see Daryl really caring
about the welfare of others not just
Sophia but Carroll to this reference
here is meant to show just how far on
this journey he's come type Tina
diabetes is a complete stranger and yet
he can't bring himself to not care about
her so Daryl's really come a long way
then we switch over to the other story
of the episode Sasha and Abraham despite
what he's used to we see that sasha is
actually the one running the show here
which makes sense because Abraham is
obviously out of his mind these days and
Sasha's actually got some good sense
about her right now best way to find a
tracker is to stay put let him find you
in fact there are some miserable 'he's
right here that i think showed just how
legit sasha has become did you notice
that after she points out that they need
to wait for Daryl to come back to them
she not only marks up a door with his
last name which is very clever because
Dixon on the door isn't going to attract
attention from anyone who isn't Daryl
but also a moment earlier she stomps her
boot in the mud to make sure Daryl's got
a way to see where they went so yeah
Sasha's definitely gotten her [ __ ]
together so the two decide to lay low
inside of this office while they wait
for Daryl to find them and kind of like
how Daryl saw a different version of
himself in the motorcyclist earlier
Abraham has his own
moment as our resident soldier guy
happens to stumble upon what appears to
be an officer's uniform and note how
Abraham examines the photograph of this
man's life in this uniform with his
whole family so this is a really good
moment to explain what the hell these
two characters are talking about in the
scene they've got all these metaphors
and playing chicken with the ground and
the [ __ ] hitting the fan stuff so what
it all means
Sasha's pointing out that Abraham is
very clearly throwing himself very
recklessly into danger as often as
possible and she knows why he's doing
this
he thinks if he's always in constant
danger he can't be held responsible for
the actions he takes over the stupid
decisions that he makes kind of like how
in the season premiere he jumped out of
a moving car without any good reason but
why is he making all these stupid
choices it's to avoid having to decide
whether or not he wants to live you seen
when they got to Alexandria which
remember in the timeline of this show
was actually very recent
they were finally off the road they
actually were in a community and it had
walls and it's relatively free from
danger and that scares the crap out of
Abraham if he's not out there fighting
Walker's or people or just being
distracted then he has to sit there and
decide does he want to start a new life
does he want to imagine living maybe
more than just another week does he want
to fall in love or start a family now
these are really tough questions for any
character to ask themselves in this
world but it's really easy to forget why
they're extra hard for Abraham you got
to remember he had a family like before
all this went down about a year ago we
learned that his family survived the
initial outbreak and they held up in a
grocery store but then some of the other
survivors raped his wife and he killed
all of these men with a freaking soup
can and it scared his family so much
that they ran off to be away from him so
when he went looking for them they were
of course dead so that's what Abraham
sees in this photograph not only his old
life with his family and that pain but
the question of starting a new family
and the possibility of having a normal
life in Alexandria that's all being
forced to the surface for him when he
looks at that and I think that's why
Ibrahim and Sasha are trapped in such a
mundane setting this is a freaking car
insurance office you can't really
pretend this [ __ ] is hitting the fan
while you're surrounded by file boxes
and auto insurance policies in fact the
show
goes even a step further to make it
clear that the Walker threat is at this
moment contained and even though
Abraham's like begging to deal with that
he can't he's finally got a deal with
the normal everyday life stuff now
Before we jump back to Daryl's story
there's another miserable detail here
that he's worth pointing out that Walker
that's trapped behind that glass they
gave us a lot of clues as to what
happened to that guy he likely suffered
a bite tried to treat his injury with
the available first-aid stuff and then
realizing that he had no way to survive
this he provided the only few services
he could think of one he leaves a
message of encouragement - he provides a
little bit of information about the
bites being fatal and three he locks
himself in the office so he can't hurt
anyone this law fine and I really loved
how much work they put into the
backstory of these walkers sometimes
great job on that jumping back to
Daryl's story he forces Dwight to trade
his little whittled piece of wood in
exchange for the insulin but because
he's still very annoyed with how they
you know bashed his head and kidnapped
him and shot him but I think he also
wants to abide by some sort of code like
the laws of bartering or something a few
times these Runaways have made it a
point to say they earned what we took
and by that logic Daryl's going by their
code of having them earn the insulin
back by giving him something side note I
love how Darryl has like no interest in
hearing a long story about Dwight's
grandpa what's that thing you're calling
grandfather okay
don't care it'll do like I wish other
characters would use that on this show
and if somebody's being totally boring
you know back on the farm we don't care
shut up oh I kind of miss Hershel now so
moments later the people that these
people ran away from and presumably the
same people that were shooting at our
friends in the beginning of the episode
they've tracked them down and the man
standing there is Wade and Dwight lets
him know that they aren't going back
we're done dealing but kneeling to who
this is all the reference to another
character that is part of the white
story the recently cast negan he doesn't
want an eel to Meighan anymore if you're
wondering how bad a guy Anakin is there
is a small clue here when in a moment
Wade says he presumably negan only
wanted to take this so far the only one
it's willing you know so that's
referring to this woman and it tells you
a bit about the role that negan makes
women play in his society need to be
assets willing not a good guy oh I know
how they're hiding this character space
which I think could be for a very
specific reason that I'm not gonna go
into but there's actually a really
interesting other tidbit here while the
camera is avoiding Wade's face we're
actually seeing things from Daryl's
point of view so the reason we focus on
his feet so much that trackers make it a
habit to notice the shoes people are
wearing in case they need to sift out
their footprints this guy has some
really fancy shoes but if it were me I
would probably trade them for like a
pair of Reeboks or running shoes but to
each their own
oh also to note did you see that after
cam gets a boo-boo Wade chops off his
arm and then he takes cams wristwatch
off making sure not to leave it behind
that's another example of this group
caring a lot about the possessions that
they've earned so jumping back over to
Abraham's storyline he comes upon a
bunch of phallic symbols even referring
to them as gentlemen it's a little like
yeah we get it
Abraham is walking testosterone but a
little bit more important in the scene
is him trying to get that RPG launcher
off that hanging Walker and look at that
it's another soldier except a soldier's
uniform before represented Abraham's
past life and his potential future life
in Alexandria and this one obviously
represents what he'll become if he keeps
up the way he has been basically a man
who's already dead but when it hits him
that this is exactly what Sasha was just
talking about Abraham realizes this is
no way to live and that's why he makes
that face that is exactly what I look
like when I've had way too much a drink
and he gives up on his pursuit of
recklessness and then just in case
Abraham might end up thinking that his
reckless decisions are the only things
that actually get him anywhere faith
smiles at him and the launcher is left
pretty much gift-wrapped for him it's a
reminder that it doesn't always have to
be about these life-or-death decisions
you can't justify always taking it to
those extremes because sometimes even in
a world this shitty luck still exists
anyway after Abraham has made the choice
to live a real life and to make real
plans for a real future he basically
spills that info to Sasha and kind of
surprisingly reveals that he wants her
to be a big part of that light of course
she's a bit too smart to just jump right
into that with a guy that has so
recently been so crazy
and she tells him you this
stuff to take care of now that's
probably referring to him getting his
mind in order but also maybe it's a
reference to Rosita
you remember Rosita yeah you got some
stuff to take care of Abraham Oh in a
quick moment you might have missed when
she says self-awareness is a beautiful
thing that's actually her quoting
exactly what Bob told her a few seasons
ago so she finally gets herself well
enough to tell that to others as we
start to wrap up this episode we start
to really see the costs of the choices
people have made with The Runaways
realizing that the fire they said to
clear this forest from a lot of Walker's
caused the death of some innocent people
that type Tina used to know we did this
we also see type Tina paying for this
stupid choice of getting too close to
dead bodies during a zombie apocalypse
and moments later we also see Daryl pain
for the trust that he put into those
people earlier he did call that decision
stupid but he made it anyway and now
we're seeing the consequences of those
choices but just like Abraham learned
earlier choosing to live choosing to be
a good person choosing a trust that
doesn't always mean you lose as fortune
smiles upon Daryl too and he's the one
who finds the patty that The Runaways
were looking for except she's a freaking
fuel truck which after food and water
and help is probably the most valuable
thing these people can find and this is
a really good moment to point out a big
parallel to the journey that Daryl has
just endured in Greek mythology there's
the story of Orpheus the great musician
who's best known for his descent into
the fires of hell to try and rescue his
recently deceased wife when he gets
there his music is so good he actually
convinces the gods of the underworld to
let him take his wife back with him but
they gave him one condition they tell
him as he walks up the steps out of the
underworld his wife is gonna walk right
behind him but he can't look back at her
if he does he's gonna lose her forever
so he does begin to lead his wife up and
out of the underworld with her following
a little bit behind but just before they
reach the exit he can't help but make
sure she's still there behind him so he
looks back and he does see her but she
immediately fades away getting sucked
back into hell and he's left alone now
compare that to this story of Daryl who
at the beginning of this journey
encounters a representation of his own
death and it marks his descent into a
land associated with only dead thing
intense fire there he encounters people
whom he wishes to rescue from this land
wanting to bring them back to the lively
world of Alexandria and just as it seems
like he has them rescued he walks ahead
of them but only when he looks back at
them does he lose him forever
and he still makes his way out of hell
through the same doorway as before that
dead body now that sounds pretty
intentional to me especially considering
one of the most famous versions of
Orpheus's story was written by the Roman
poet Ovid and that name might sound
familiar if you watch my video on the
last episode because as I mentioned
there that quote that Deanna is
scrolling on her plans that's also from
a story of Ovitz you got big Ovid fans
I'm walking dead I'm not hating I keep
keep it up I love it ok so we're nearing
the end just before Daryl picks up the
rest of the team and we see Abraham
confirmed that his arc is complete like
Sasha kept telling him earlier he had
two choices except here it's between the
version of the two soldiers he wants to
be and he's picked the one with
happiness the one with the family except
did you notice Abraham removed all the
medals that adorn the jacket before it's
not only because Abraham would never
embrace the false honor of wearing
another man's awards it also means he
knows he's got to earn his own medals
and his own awards and his own happiness
as they drive back to Alexandria we get
our closing images and in contrast to
our opening images of the Horde behind
them and the shitstorm that Abraham had
previously wanted to get mixed up in no
time out here he's looking into that
side bearer and he sees that the road is
clear there's nothing following them
he's finally free from his baggage state
again oh ok really quick just two
lingering thoughts one Abraham was so
damned quotable this week even if he did
start to sound a lot more like Eugene
than himself and while I really did
enjoy the euphemism he used for his
penis
our precious leather I got a prefer the
great loosened make my ass itch because
yeah I agree with you buddy loose ends
up and - it would suck to have diabetes
in the apocalypse like especially since
apparently this stuff needs to stay cold
that's not gonna happen sorry buddy now
my questions for you one her Abraham is
choosing to live he wants happiness he
wants a life with Sasha
so is Abraham about to die - does anyone
have any ideas why the show might have
focused on this soldiers patch I see
that it says airborne and it looks like
a crow maybe sitting on a crown that
makes a lot more sense as a
Game of Thrones referenced in has a
walking dead one so what do you think
that means three when Daryl and the two
Runaways are having that intense
exchange we're sorry
you're gonna be do we think Daryl means
because of what he's gonna do to them in
the future
or does he mean that they'll be sorry
that they didn't go back with him to
Alexandria see personally I think it's
the latter because I could see Dwight's
betrayal having an iron hey twist some
of you get that that's it for this
week's Walking Dead breakdown what up
freakin doozy make sure watch last
week's if you haven't there's lots of
fun stuff in there and also I just
started doing flash ones to maybe arrow
I haven't decided yet we'll see I check
those out though hit me up on Twitter at
fimo if you have any questions for me
follow add new rockstars to keep up with
our video upload schedule though
otherwise make sure to subscribe so you
get the next Walking Dead video that
one's gonna be about season 6 episode 7
called heads up it's supposed to just
keep getting more intense until the
mid-season finale which is like two
freaking episodes I've been full of
Molina and that's it for me
bye